so
so at this point you've watched they've
conditioned your mind they got to kill
your heart they got to get you to
realize that this is a normal life so
this is not gonna you know uh hurt you
you're getting colder
you're you know becoming a little bit
more uh
acceptance of the life of uh what it
could like to be your day
and going through this so now what what
happens next
after this where you actually get to see
uday and at what point do you start
spending more time with saddam hussein
because they didn't want him to be in
public
in dangerous places they wanted you to
be in public what ways were you used
between the training i was meeting all
day time to time he come on it's not
like
i finished meeting him it was time to
time he come on to see
and where we are and how we talk and
and he was laughing you know he was
really laughing and
i don't know why but he was laughing
anyway
after all this finished
they come and go have a shower go have
this
go have that
a doctor come on he tested me
and my mouth hand that was like they
have
tissues cleaning my hand they bring
brand new suit brancher everything
new from shoes socks everything is new
what's going on
is don't ask we got to see
about an hour later car come on
money i'm with me another car behind us
and this is where i met the president
for first time
how was his demeanor when you met him
how was he with you
uh he was sitting in his desk and he was
writing something and just put his head
up
and he smiled
[Music]
and he looked at me welcome on me
he shake my hand sit down i
said was very good
very nice not what we hear about him
funny uh
he said god they give me two sons you
are the third now
anything you want ask anything
in your dream just ask
but try don't make me hungry only this
word
and i said sure sir i don't do anything
make you angry but to be fair
you know he liked me
he really liked me you know he never
hurt me
he always called me a son and he meant
it when he said to me
he always say to my shoulder everything
okay nobody upsetting you no i'm okay
perfect that's it god and at this point
your family
you're not in contact with your family
does your family know what's going on or
no
my family they told them
what is he being killed in the world
but his body we can't get him iranian
pass this line and we can get him
they did a funeral for me nobody know
latif is a different place and
that's it even uh i still have the
picture of
this the black sign they put when
somebody killed in the war
my name in it and i have the video of
my funeral you have the video of your
funeral
yes i have it uh yeah
i have all these photos they took
[Music]
for the funeral as an army person he
killed in the war
how long from from that until they found
out you're alive how many years was that
less than two oh less than two years
until they found that
okay got it so so now you're in the
family
saddam's calling you his son i had two
now i have three
anybody making you upset you know cry
don't make me hungry you know he's
telling you all this of his mindset
um when did you start seeing how uday
lived
and how he behaved
i saw him i think second week
of when i was in the palace when he was
coming you know
he bring girls with him oh if you like
somebody take her take her like
you know lucky
take her you know i said no
i'm here for something else
but uh after i finish
all these training he start coming
uh if he don't want me to go for him as
a body
double uh he said okay you come and
party
partying with me shave your beard
okay shave your beard i'll just be
mustard
i dress like a just normal food i carry
in a gun and
all that and go behind him with him in
his car
but the parties i was seeing uh
i don't think a king or friend
or playboy in the world do these parties
when you say that what do you mean by
that well give us a little bit of
description
one of the parties was his birthday
with a lot of
friend close friend to him i don't think
he have a friend but
i call them pimp i'm sorry for this
world but this is the reality
what i saw i call them temps because
they bring in girls
they do every dirty thing just to be
close to him
one of the party was his birthday about
50 girls there
and about 20 what called friend
and i was in a corner
having my cigar on a cognac beside me
just past 12 o'clock he took his machine
gun and start
shooting here and there he was
absolutely
blocked drunk
everyone's struck everyone takes the
clothes
everyone took the clothes out all of
them
you don't see any clothes in the place
man and woman this is one of the
craziest things
really tell now the picture i can
imagine that i was there
so they take their clothes off everybody
took their clothes off
yeah and then what happened
okay got it so everybody he was just
asking to okay
i got it it makes sense